right we are
now live for the april ama that is
ask me anything session and we'll go
about an hour and a half
i see a lot of questions for me here
already
and unfortunately i don't see some of
the questions that i
saw people posting earlier today so i'm
not sure what the
what the issue is with youtube with that
but i do remember
one of them at least had to do with
philosophy of science
and the you know problem of demarcating
you know science from from other things
so
i'm going to take a stab at what i can
remember
glancing at it seeing there this morning
and then i'll i'll pick up some
some of these other questions that
people have posted so the question was
basically about
how do we um set out lines or criteria
that differentiates
real science from things that pretend to
be science but but aren't science and do
i
follow you know this person or this
person on it and i'm i'll tell you i'm
not a philosopher or science person to
begin with i had to study some of that
back
in grad school but it's not an area of
my focus but there are two
closely connected things that do fit
into my
reading research interests one of those
is differentiating between disciplines
per se right so not just like
you know is this is this uh science or
is this pseudoscience or is this science
or is this philosophy of science or
things like that but also like
where does philosophy end and something
else begin or vice versa and i think
those are
important things to explore um
and i'll talk about that in just a
minute the other thing that i do want to
say
is i think that in our time it's not
just about fallout
it's not just about science versus
pseudoscience
very often you can have
good well-done scientific studies and
then the way that they're reported
steers us into something that i'm not
going to call pseudoscience but i'm
going to call
badly you know reported or badly
interpreted
science where people make all sorts of
vast
sweeping claims and this happens with
you know interpretations
of things in food and nutrition
this happens when it comes to really
anything that has to do with psychology
you know we did a few studies on
28 subjects and now we know that there's
an absolute difference between people of
this type and this type
that's the way reporters report it and
in the process
um what could be originally decent
science and then there's a lot of you
know
how did you set up the study did you
tweak the the
information that you got you know
massage the statistics as we say or did
you actually like you know
do do good interpretation let's assume
everything's okay on that
end by the time that it comes out you
know of a think tank or
science reporting or something like that
it might be absolute garbage
and and you know just fit into ideology
and that's often the case in our society
so i think that part of the discipline
of critical thinking is
actually helping people to differentiate
between
those those two when it comes back to
the question of like how do you
set down border lines between like you
know say philosophy on this side and
and it could be history of philosophy it
could be you know
science it could be uh religion and
theology
it could be sight you know philosophy
and psychology all of these dividing
lines are arbitrary
none of them are universally bought into
by anybody
on either side and they almost always
involve philosophical assumptions
in how the lines are are drawn so i
prefer to look at it in terms of like
continua
rather than sharp dividing lines a lot
of very schematic thinkers
love those sorts of things where you can
say well here's the here's the
definition but
the problem is is that within the world
of um
philosophy you know
it and its history you can take any one
of those things and like just take the
difference between philosophy and
theology there isn't any agreed-upon
thing there's there's locally agreed
upon you know
dividing lines and then those will lose
their validity in about 100 years when
nobody in that community is really doing
anything
anymore so so i think that's that's an
important issue to
to think about all right so i don't
remember what the other questions that
people had posed before
uh all these other questions came in
were so perhaps if they're here they can
repost those
i'm gonna take the questions that are
here now so isaac says
where do your students struggle the most
when reading the euthyphro or the meno
thanks for all the content it's been
helpful so um
yeah that's a good question uh where do
they struggle the most
i would say you know most of my students
in general throughout my career
they don't have a background in
philosophy and they're not getting much
of
background in philosophy as content and
they're also
not getting introduced even if they have
like instructors
who pride themselves on using the
socratic method
usually they're they're not you know
they're it's done by like high school
teachers who don't know anything about
socrates
uh quite frankly and so usually i get
people who are like
proverbially off the bus right and
they find it very difficult sometimes to
figure out
exactly what is being put forward
sometimes because the texts themselves
are
are tricky and the translations i use
public domain translations
rather than you know very recent
translations so sometimes the
old-fashioned language can be an
obstacle to them
but you know figuring out um who is
saying what and why
is often a difficulty for for students
i think another big problem and i i
won't say that this is like
a you know a stumbling block in terms of
the content but
i think a lot of students don't realize
that you need to
read and reread these texts multiple
times
in order to really understand what's
going on and it may be useful to like
check out secondary sources in between
readings
um but you know reading a philosophy
text is not the same thing
as reading a novel
unless it's a very philosophical novel
right like dostoevsky or
our scott back or ursula kayla green
so those are some problems um
i think a lot of students you know when
it comes to the amino this is actually a
great question
when it comes to the amino and when it
comes to the euthyphro i think a lot of
students
approach them with um
the mindset of let's call it
christian atheist polemics right so
they have a monotheistic conception of
god
in mind and um
that's not what the ancient greeks were
working with certainly not in those
dialogues you know in in the euthyphro
gods get angry with each other so that's
you know that's kind of a that's ruled
out basically in classical
theism um and atheists you know love to
like where's the youthful dilemma right
and they're too focused on that and
they're not focused enough about
on what else is going on in the dialogue
and what the arguments actually are you
know so people come to you can say
with filters or an agenda and that
stands in the way of genuine
comprehension of the text and what's
being said and its importance
um with amino you know it's not um
obviously the the euthyphro dilemma
that's at stake instead it's like
the um doctrine of recollection and
it's it's connection to like being in a
previous life so there's a
there's a metaphysics of the soul
involved and people are like oh yeah i i
i understand that that's like
christianity well
no not exactly you know it's it's quite
different
and you know atheists will be there's no
such thing as a soul you know well let's
actually see what plato's saying you
know um
before we reject that out of hand so i
think students that are too committed to
those sort of things that come up in
essentially the intellectual culture
wars
stand in their own way of understanding
the texts so
all right let me take this question from
from mickey is anxiety an all-consuming
unhistorical state or is there a scale
to it when
where and when does a metaphysics uh
understanding take place during anxiety
so
if you're talking about something like
high to gary and anxiety or angst
um is it a unhistorical state
it unhistorical in the sense that it
would be present for
human beings qua human beings throughout
their history
sure but i mean for somebody like
heidegger or really anybody else who
picks up on that notion of
anxiety is being there but being covered
over um we exist in history so
it's not a totally a historical state
right um
you would be your anxiety would be
oriented by
things so like when i was a kid there
was a lot of anxiety about the fact that
um the us and the soviet union were
basically poised to blow up the planet
and if they didn't do that maybe a a
world war would break out
of nato versus uh the soviet union and
warsaw pact
and then we'd you know like we wouldn't
finish high school we'd get drafted and
probably die
and i can tell you that when i was a
combat engineer
in the army stationed in germany uh not
that far from the czech border
and you know this is before the wall
came down and the velvet revolution and
and you know the soviet union
opening up and all that that sort of
stuff um you know we
were we had a sort of sense of anxiety
about the fact that we had a 30-minute
lifespan if there was a war
as combat engineers and the fact that um
we
were constantly doing training about
nuclear biological chemical
weapons and we had to be worried about
nerve gas and stuff like that so
you know i mean the anxiety can be can
be
uh oriented by historical situations or
by
what what your own smaller history
is you know if you've been um
traumatized
then anxiety can kind of like you know
center on that so
i think you know if you if you accept
that
um that notion and there's kind of like
a continuum
there's like anxiety about having
freedom and being responsible for it
this is something the existentialists
talk about a lot and then there's
anxiety like
the oh [ __ ] what's going to happen you
know and
there it sort of can fade into more
determinate fears and then there's all
this other stuff
in between um so
that's that's sort of an existentialist
take on on all of that
um all right natalie says
many seem to think the west is going
through a meeting crisis of some kind
that nihilism is
increasingly pervasive in our culture
you would love to hear my thoughts on
this
i think that that is the case but i also
think that it's not something new
it's like you know people maybe every 20
years or so
start recycling this stuff but it's not
it's not something
radically new i mean nietzsche thought
and this is back
in the um you know
in the end of the 19th century
not even in its last decade in the 1880s
that
nihilism was like the coming crisis for
the 20th century
um and you know what are we gonna do
about it and i think there's there's
something to that
there's a great book by michael
harrington that was written in the early
80s called the politics at god's funeral
you know this this is a something that
we've been noticing for a long time
and there is there is a lot of stuff
that's ultimately you could say
grounded on nothing even though it
appears to be
you know quite robust a lot of appeals
to tradition
are quite you know frankly nihilistic
when you get down to what what tradition
counts for the
these people that are doing it
but it's you know it's manageable
um it's it's you know it's not something
that we don't have like a long track
record of people attempting to
conceptualize
and and deal with so i think there's a
lot of resources
out there for addressing it
um thanks to elijah that's that's very
nice uh if you have a question
i'll look for for that um
rapa says if you had the chance to redo
your dissertation on blondel
what would your new subject be okay so
that's a great question
my dissertation looking back on it and i
haven't looked at it for years
is kind of a hot mess you know i never
actually published more than a little
bit of it
i think i was trying to work with too
much
you know i was doing some very big
picture
philosophy and ideas and history stuff
all at once and i was working with a lot
of his
untranslated um later works like the
trilogy
i think if i were going to so there's a
couple of things if i was going to write
a new dissertation
on anybody it would be a much more
manageable
you know very structured i'm going to do
this
this this and this and nothing else
outside of this
sort of approach and and i suggest that
anybody who is working
not just on a dissertation but a
master's thesis or even a bachelor's
thesis
uh the advice that one of my advisors
gave me is the only good dissertation is
a done dissertation
and that that is quite true you've got
to pick something that's that's much
more manageable
i i you know i've thought many times
that what i should have done
instead of writing on blondel for my
dissertation i should have done that
later on just you know for my own uh
stuff as i did with you know the my book
the um
reason fulfilled by revelation where i
translated four of
blondel's um contributions to the
uh 1930s christian philosophy debates um
and then i wrote a long historical
introduction
i should have just written like a
dissertation on anselm and the history
of the ontological argument or
you know blondel on this thing
over here or aristotle on anger
you know any of the other things that i
was really quite interested in
but what would have been much more
manageable if i was
uh let's say i'm because obviously i'm
in a different situation now i don't i
don't have the time to write a
dissertation
but let's say i did let's say somebody
gave me a fellowship and they're like we
want you to do another dissertation on
blown dell
i'm like oh thank you very much um
what would i write on now i mean i think
i would probably
discuss i think the thing i would be the
most interested in discussing quite
frankly
would be what the still has yet
untranslated metaphysical trilogy which
is five volumes
what it it it contributes why
why it's valuable you know this guy
wrote
um oxio 1893 in 1893 that was his
doctoral dissertations great stuff
uh he wrote some other you know fairly
shorter works after that
a lot of things that were both timely
and polemical
and then in the 1930s he began work
while he was nearly blind and having to
do this by dictation
um on this this metaphysical trilogy
and you know he's taking his thoughts
and sort of like
reworking them that's probably what i
would
be most interested in focusing on you
know
all right uh arvid malm philosopher greg
what is your opinion on the
overabundance of online pornography
these days do you think it's harmful for
the younger generation
yes it's undoubtedly harmful in
different ways
um and i have a i'm laughing because i
have something that i say to my classes
sometimes that always gets them laughing
so imagine that a bunch of aliens have
been like watching
us for centuries and they're like holy
crap look at these people they're
you know their their technological boom
is happening
and then they're like you know they've
got all this great communication stuff
you know radio waves
tv you know it's no longer just wireless
and all that
and then they they see us like you know
developing cable
and you know uh computers and networks
of the computers and
boom we have the internet right and
they're like all right they're
they're finally almost ready to join the
you know united federation of worlds you
know like a civilized
uh species and then they watch for
another couple decades
and then they're like wow they're using
a lot of their bandwidth for just a
couple
things we should look at this more
carefully
and then what do they find that we use
the majority of our bandwidth for
well you know um there's there's lots of
business related stuff a lot of which is
is ultimately quite trivial
but massive amounts of porn massive
amounts of gaming
and they'd be like uh
it's one of those species
and um i mean on the one hand
we know technologically that uh
pornography has driven development
in uh media you know like down to like
why
vhs uh became more popular than beta or
you know
how all these things were done with the
internet on the other hand there's lots
of downsides right and and they
are all over the map you know people get
um
very unrealistic ideas about um
sexuality from
from pornography um you know
gearing towards more and more extreme
stuff they can interfere
sort of like you know with how how you
understand what what a genuine intimate
relationship would be like
uh leads to lots of pressure on on
people to engage in this
or that particularly when they're
they're younger
people become addicted um there's
exploitation of the
the people involved in it um even if you
have like full consent there's i would
say there's a lot of economic
exploitation involved and we could go on
and on and on
and so it's it's a real problem there's
not much you can actually
do about it in terms of like closing the
pipe gates right
that's not going to happen unless you're
living literally like
under a rock with no internet access so
what do we need instead um you know we
probably need way better sex ed classes
earlier on where people are like listen
you're probably gonna see porn
here's what you should know about it
here's why this is not realistic here's
why
you don't want to be watching this you
know three four hours a day
here's the signs of being addicted um
you know and that could be tied in with
internet addiction as well
um we probably need a much more like
virtue ethics
uh orientation towards it than the
you know don't do it you know that we
know that that's not even useful for
like abstinence
education put porn aside um
you know abstinence only sex ed actually
leads to more stds and pregnancies
typically so
so we really you know we need to do more
when it comes to that um
mickey asks uh what is martin
heidegger's justification for using
attunement
as a means of metaphysical inquiry so
attunement means mood
right and we can call that modes of
affectivity
and justification i mean
moods are revelatory aristotle actually
noted this way back in
the rhetoric book too you know they
affect the way in which we
review things so i don't think he
particularly has to
to justify that and actually he mentions
that
aristotle's book 2 is like a primary
example of an early hermeneutics of
affectivity in being in time
heidegger conceives of
our experience as um
human beings in the world as having
four what he calls equi-primordial we
can call them dimensions or whatever and
equi-primordial means none of them are
more basic than the other
they're all equally basic and
mood or attunement is one of them um
pre-understanding the projections that
we make
you know every situation we go into
we're bringing
we're bringing to bear the things that
we think we know or or believe or assume
throneness which is the sort of the
present you know the the situation that
we're in
and then language or um however you want
to translate
discourse is how the stombac translates
it
in german and these all interpenetrate
each other um
so you know that's that's important and
and you know
paying attention to emotions
not just in the sense of mindfulness
like what are you feeling right now let
the feeling wash over you
and observe it you know but i actually
like genuine metaphysical
inquiry into the nature of human
emotions and affectivity
that can be extraordinarily revealing
um and heidegger is not the only
phenomenologist to to realize this
you know mark schaeler spends a lot of
time on this gabriel marcel who's
another contemporary spends a lot of
time
on this as does bergson who is not
calling what he does phenomenology but
it's really phenomenology
you know um so i i think that's
that's part of what you know what the
answer to that would be
all right let's uh let's look at the
next one
um john says i'm interested in exploring
christianity more should i start with
the old testament or the new testament
and any recommended sections
i mean you should start by like talking
to people who practice that
seem to be well put together to you as
well you know you
it's not just it's it's not as if like
the bible which by the way is a whole
bunch of books
um biblia is simply the foundation and
then
you know everything flows out of that
that's a particularly
um sort of hyper-protestant way of
looking at it that would actually
exclude most protestants have any sort
of tradition like say lutherans or
anglicans or
presbyterians um you know you want to
engage with um people who've been shaped
by christianity
if you want to understand it as well as
you know some of the core texts so i
would say you know like reading
augustine's confessions can be
just as useful for you as reading um
you know the book of judges if you want
a challenging book by the way that's
that's that's a tough one right um
christianity you know the the new
testament is
uh going to be much more normative
but there's a lot of things that are
carried forward every time you see in
the new testament it is written that
that's a citation of of uh scripture you
know so
christ for example is in the in the
synagogue and he's unrolling a scroll
and it's isaiah and he's reading it and
interpreting it for people so
you know they kind of go hand in hand
there are um
parts of the old testament that i would
say are probably not that that
particularly
interesting or worth reading at first
like a lot of the historical books or
some of the minor prophets
if you're philosophically inclined you
want you want to read the wisdom
literature
which would include things like you know
ecclesiastes or coleth right the prophet
talking about that
um song of songs the psalms
proverbs wisdom of sirach book of wisdom
with solomon
you know those are those are all kind of
heavy hitters some of them are not in
the protestant canon but they're in the
catholic and orthodox and
ethiopian coptic or you know
all the older early churches that are
apostolic contained them
um you know the new testaments
the gospels are i mean if you want to
know what this what this
jesus guy was like um you probably want
to read the gospels because that's
people talking about that guy right
um you know if you're going to read
paul's letters you should also read
peter james and
you know these other letter writers who
are equally normative but not as
quite as prolific um jude too
so but i would say you know you also
want to like you know you want to
if you're going to read it maybe you
read it with other people who
are grounded in it you know so
all right made of clay i'm just
beginning to learn about a division
between analytic and continental
philosophy
and was curious if universities focus on
one more than the other
regard one is more important oh yeah
definitely not
universities programs programs in
universities
so if you go to some places it may be
that they have a few people not just
doing analytic philosophy but almost
everybody's doing
analytic whereas other places it can be
mostly continentals
but those are only two of many different
ways
and traditions of doing philosophy and
they're both pretty recent
there's the entire field of history of
philosophy which includes everything
from like you know studying the history
for its own sake to philosophy as a way
of life
you know like pure odor or john sellers
kind of stuff
and everything in between there's
classical american philosophy which
isn't just pragmatism but also includes
jonathan edwards and the saint louis
hegelians
and the transcendentalists and and you
know all sorts of people today
there's you know marxism has a tradition
there's there's all sorts of radical um
uh
philosophies available as well that
don't fit neatly into continental or
analytic and are often you know part of
the great sequence of american
philosophy
we can talk about africana philosophy
that kind of overlaps with that as well
and which would include uh people in the
americas
uh as well as people in africa right um
and so there's there's all sorts of dif
well
there's comparative philosophy right
even we haven't even talked about
chinese and indian philosophy but there
are people who like
specialize in talking about aristotle
and comparison to
the confucian tradition so there's all
these different things
and i think people often get very bogged
down and thinking oh
i've got to be on team this or team that
and really
you know this isn't an answer to the
question but i'm going to say this just
as something i think needs to be
reinforced
it's your life and your brain and your
reading and your study and your time so
you get to do whatever the hell you want
with it
you know even if you're like a graduate
student
at a place that's super into analytic
philosophy
and you know denigrates everything else
there's no reason why you have to buy
into that
and you can't go home and read some
nietzsche you know or read simone de
bouvoir if you want to
or you know read read whoever you like
right you can read things that don't
count as philosophy that people will say
that's just
literature right it's your life
you can do what you want with it and
you don't have to necessarily get into
anybody's
program about how philosophy has to be
done the older you get and the more that
you
travel around you the more that you find
that these like you have to do things
this way this way this way
turn out to be all [ __ ] you know and
wishful thinking you know
on the part of the people putting them
together
all right govind says what's my thoughts
on korbinsky's work
science insanity on general semantics
overall does it have any value so
there's there's another tradition right
in in philosophy
and another area where philosophy bleeds
over into other disciplines like
linguistics
um you know i think it's good um and i'm
trying to remember there's another guy
associated with that i think he's a
student of cour
krabinski hayakawa is that sound right
to anybody who's a
and their books are good um
they're you know they've got their
shtick right and
uh it's interesting because somebody who
i like very much as an
author as a science fiction author
really got into
that stuff and that's a van vote who has
a
institute for general semantics existing
in the future
in the world of null a he was so
impressed with that
um i don't think that they have the
like monopoly on on
you know intelligent discussion of
language but i think
you know the stuff that they they did
was was quite interesting
all right jb says i've just started i
stones the trial of socrates what's your
take on the hot take that socrates is
actually an anti-democratic aristocrat
um okay so that that's an interesting
take
um i do not think that he was an
aristocrat
i would say that he
he was definitely you know a critic of
democracy
um but he also you know he didn't he
didn't he was a
this is where we get into really
interesting stuff like we have a broader
um uh implications
socrates is sort of a good example of
somebody who takes virtue very seriously
and if you are not necessarily virtuous
but at least taking virtue seriously
you are going to have a hard time buying
into
a lot of existing political uh movements
and associations and so
democracy there's problems with that
oligarchy which
aristocracies typically tend to be
problems with that
tyranny problems with that socrates
diagnosis all of them
as a matter of fact when people talk
about plato and what about plato's
republic
it's very important to remember that in
book two
socrates actually defines what the ideal
city is and it's
not the ideal city of book two
on through book seven is it because
that's
actually what's the ideal city it's this
place where you know we've got a
shoemaker and a
you know farmer maybe a couple farmers
and a
builder and i forget who else we have
and they subside on pretty simple food
and then glaucon comes along and says
socrates this life sucks they don't have
like relish for their meat and socrates
says oh
i know i understand you don't want the
perfect city you want the inflamed city
and that's
what we see represented in the republic
right it's not a
the best or plato's model or something
like that
socrates is a problematizer um
so you know a critic of democracy yeah
an aristocrat
only in the sense that like he would be
for an
aristocracy that doesn't exist an
aristocracy
aristocracy of the you know ari stoy the
genuinely
virtuous people aristotle by the way
is hip to that as well in the politics
towards
towards the end i think this is in book
six
book seven i don't i don't quite
remember exactly where when he's talking
about
what you need in a city he says
you know you're going to have the many
and they represent certain interests and
you're going to have the rich
and you can't get away from that and
they're both kind of steering things
towards democracy or oligarchy if you
want things to go right you also need
the aristoi the the good
the people who like keep things together
and don't buy
into these these class things that both
are willing to corrupt society for and
you know you're never going to have the
the ari stoy actually like being the
whole of the
place or ruling most of the time but
they need to be part
they need to be there at the table or
else you're going to have some real
problems
so all right uh
so here's a question from elijah did i
ever hear of the philosopher jacques
i've not only heard of him i've read
some of his stuff a long time ago
um interesting as far as i remember i
haven't taken a look at him
lately but he is you know an important
uh philosopher of technology another
area i don't do a lot of work in
uh but you know would enjoy doing some
work in i think
if i had the time you know
i wish i had more time i was talking
with somebody about this yesterday
and i used it as an example you know
like it what would i want if i could
have it
every day to be 48 hours that would be
awesome wouldn't it
so all right
uh let's take a look at the next one um
reuben in what order should i read kant
his
major five books also should i focus on
interpretations and critics before or
after reading a text
even if both is best um
you don't have to like read them in any
particular order i say this every time
whatever order you pick you're going to
be re-reading so it's not like
first you you get this down and then you
get this down
i mean the before you read the uh
first critique the critique of pure
reason you might want to read the thing
that kant calls the prologumana
to be read to be read beforehand right
um
so that that's important the second
critique is an easier way easier read at
least for me
it's shorter too then the second
then the first critique and you probably
want to read
um the groundwork for the metaphysics of
morals before that
um and then there's also the actual like
metaphysics of morals you know which has
two parts
virtue justice that's that's definitely
worth reading
i find the moral philosophy you know
easier to make your way through than the
epistemology stuff
um the critique of judgment is wow
that's like
all sorts of things jumbled up together
um
and i think a lot of people never go on
to read that when they're reading hunt
um and then he's got all sorts of like
little essays here and there that are
worth checking out
but you're gonna be like going back and
forth and
do you want to use uh secondary sources
sure
you know you can use whatever you like
just realize that every secondary source
is a secondary source
you know and
same thing goes for my videos you know
people um
i had an exchange just this week with
somebody who was like talking about
uh camus right and and um they were
going by what was in my video which are
you know
not the whole work um i had to do
something with the absurd and i was like
you got to read the text there's no way
around that you have to read the text
but that doesn't mean you have to read
the text all the way through
every single time with kant's first
critique that that is you know a
significant investment
um and you know it's it's worth reading
through
and understanding just like so many
other philosophical works but
you probably could also get by with some
good summaries as well
uh william vandenberg do i have any
experience with psychedelics in specific
lsd or acid no i've never taken that
sort of stuff
um the only things that i've had is you
know when i was
under grad and grad student plenty of
drinking
uh actually when i was in the army too
in high school
and uh you know when i was in in grad
school you know
carbondale illinois it was a heavy pot
area so i smoked a bit but i didn't
enjoy it very much
um mostly because i don't like hanging
around potheads that much
and uh what else um
tried ecstasy once but you know i was i
was drunk and high at the time so i
don't know if
it meant anything and i got dosed with
uh pcp
by somebody who laced uh uh some stuff
with it and that was not pleasant at all
um but that's about it and and i'm not
one of these like open the third eye
you know open the doors of consciousness
kind of person when it comes to
psychedelics um so
yeah all right uh plato's rave any
thoughts on nick land and the ccru
i don't really pay attention to nick
land people
used to ask me about them all the time
now not so much
i've you know over and over again said
if somebody actually wants to put a
book a copy of fang numina in my hands i
will read it and
comment on it but nobody's done that so
far
so uh keith says are you familiar with
the regic putnam argument that special
relativity
implies a deterministic block universe
uh
what are your favorite works on the
question of free will i am not familiar
with that but i don't i don't pay much
attention
you know uh to to that sort of stuff
myself
um favorite works on on free will
there's all sorts of
great works out there where it's a topic
you know it comes up in descartes
metaphysics
uh obviously the whole cartesian
tradition there's a lot of discussion
of it there's a lot of discussion of it
in medieval philosophy
including in aquinas and anselm and
augustine and boethius and
i mean there's like an entire vast
literature
out there on the the issue of free will
but the thing that you always have to be
wary of is there's no such thing as the
question of free will
there's just a whole bunch of different
discussions and they don't always mean
the same thing by free will so you
always got to look carefully at what's
what's actually being
being said there pointsman any
suggestions for getting into stoic
logic and metaphysics
well um
yeah so we don't have any
works of stoic logic per se
um like we know that you know say seneca
and epictetus
and and marcus and other people were
able to read and epictetus probably
taught
uh crucifix you know you look at in
endogenous layers it's the catalog
of his works and and most of them were
logical works
so you can get like rudiments of it here
and there
but we don't have a single work for
stoic logic
somebody might have compiled all the
fragments together into some text
um i actually have a project that i'm
i'm you know interested in working on
just bringing together all the
syllogistic arguments that we find in
the works and then you know talking
about them and unpacking them because
the stoics love to argue
using syllogisms so much that cicero
actually said you guys
could go way too far with that um now
the metaphysics
okay so there's you know some of the
letters of seneca bear directly on
metaphysics so i would read some of the
you know letters um particularly for
example uh letter 65 um
i mean you see little bits and pieces
here and marcus
you know marcus aurelius's meditations
is not a systematic work at all
but you see him saying things that are
reflective
of it say same thing you can say in
certain parts of epictetus
but you know i think for a lot of this
you want to go to um
to cicero who's not a stoic but knows
the stoics very well
so if you want to understand their
theology you know on the nature of the
gods that's the place to go
if you want to understand their ideas
about freedom and determinism
on fate is an important one
on divination as well is important so
yeah all right mf um
have i read any of paulo b preciando's
books criticizing freudian
accounting and psychoanalysis i've never
even heard of the guy so no
skin in the academic game i've noticed
some scientists and
mathematicians might explicitly adhere
to idealism is this the case
it seems that the positivism of compt is
based on pure ideas rather than material
reality i
i wouldn't know about that with with
compt but i that that's
that seems rather suspect to me um
i mean there are some mathematicians who
in math
philosophy of mathematics we don't call
it idealism we call it platonism
to think that um mathematical objects
have real existence of their own
independent of
you know whatever we're doing with
mathematics um
i don't know about scientists per se i
know more about mathematicians but
yeah they're they're out there i guess
uh mark says how's it going hope you're
keeping well i'm doing okay
um i actually
gave my students a week to catch up
because some of them are not doing okay
you know
i put that into the semester um but
uh i'm doing i'm doing good on my end i
hope you are too
truth to power were there any
philosophers that believed and promoted
social chaos i'm writing a fictional
work and would love to flesh out a
certain character
um promoted social chaos
i mean some people would say that
nietzsche was
right um lev shestoff certainly
you know thought that things are a lot
messier you know you could talk about
people like saying
um i'm not just gonna like stir the pot
and make everything chaotic but rather
i'm gonna recognize that things are not
as well
laid out as as you think i mean the the
character and
uh dostoevsky's notes from the
underground is kind of a pot stir
that way all right um so there's yeah
there's people out there
i don't know about any who's like i love
chaos and you know we should have more
of it because
it's a bit of a self-defeating thing if
you're gonna go through all the work to
get published
you know how chaotic are you um
all right uh t mag
maggio your lectures on certain marks
have been really helpful and i'm curious
what do you think about the proposition
that marx is a proto-existentialist well
anybody can be a proto-existentialist
depending on what you mean by
existentialism right if it's about like
focusing
on lived reality and practicalities
yeah marx can fit in there i guess um
certainly a lot of existentialists drew
on marx
although some of them hated his guts or
hated his followers guts you know
um so you know
and and you know he apparently he and
kierkegaard were in the same classroom
at certain times but didn't really know
each other
but i don't know what's actually gained
by viewing marx as a
proto-existentialist i think that's the
question
you've got to ask um what it what what
what would that tell us you know i mean
we can also say pascal's a
proto-existentialist or
augustine is how how is what marx is
doing different than
what what they're doing right
all right uh gabrielle which ancient
philosopher would you be most interested
in having a conversation with
that's a good question um
i mean
probably cicero you know i'm a big fan
of his
um he'd probably i don't know if he'd
enjoy
hanging out with me though you know um
but yeah he's probably the one
all right uh kolomos do you think
plato's earlier dialogues are
underappreciated and or
underutilized no i mean
they're they get taught they get red
they get discussed
um they get drawn upon they often
don't arrive at the um
you know full exposition of the matter
that they were
supposed to be about so like a good
example of the lock ace
you know do we really know what courage
is we thought we did at the start but
now
now it turns out it's murkier well we've
learned some things along the way
um i mean i would say plato's dialogues
as such are underutilized and
underappreciated
in philosophy in general especially by
people who like to say oh philosophy is
just a set of footnotes to plato
and then you're like oh that's cool did
you which which dialogues do you like
and they're like
they don't have any answer because they
just have this one little
quip um i think you know reading plato
is
is uh quite important and should be part
of everybody's
uh undergraduate education not to become
a platonist as such but because it's
it's worth doing it
um tullius you speak about the
importance of making good distinctions
what are some distinctions you found in
your life to be most important or
fruitful
what distinctions do we find we fail to
make
so um i mean the stoics are totally
right about there is a distinction
between
you know the judgment that you have been
affected in this way
and actually being affected in that way
that's something they drive home all the
time
um a lot of distinctions that i find i i
you know make with other people that
that they find quite helpful usually are
like hey you know that word has more
than one use
very simple stuff right you're talking
about this they're talking about this
distinguishing between means and ends
and different means
distinguishing between what question
we're actually discussing at the time
is very important you know keeping
questions
separated out from each other because
people will often and this happens a lot
in political discussions they'll be like
yeah but what about and then you're like
that's a legitimate question that has
nothing to do with this over here
and so you know you've got to make a
case for how that has to do with this
over here
those are those are examples um
all right uh edwin boyette says
thoroughly appreciate the self-study
lectures
i need to do more of them hopefully this
summer
what was your mos in the army so i was a
12 bravo which means i was a combat
engineer
and which you know basically for those
of you who don't know
that means you're essentially like
infantry but with less of the
you know sort of squad and platoon
weapons and kind of bumped up in terms
of
dealing with um traditional engineer
stuff so
minefields obstacles like concertina
wire stuff
building bridges although we didn't do
any of that germany thank god because
i hated building bridges um
destroying obstacles demolition
you know all that sort of stuff falls
under the engineer's purview but they
could be like
brought in to be used as infantry
and you know within an engineer's squad
i don't know i mean i don't know what
it's like today but
within an engineer squad which was uh
not the 11-man
infantry squad uh but was you know six
to eight people you'd have two people
with
m203s that's grenade launchers i carried
one of those
on on my rifle and then one person with
like an anti-tank weapon so you're kind
of like
you're beefed up a bit but you don't
have like the the automatic weapons that
everybody else does
in part because i guess if we were not
um you know we we were mechanized so we
had these armored personnel
carriers um which were actually like
vietnam vintage
m113s just filled with the gills with
crap
you know all sorts of tools that we'd
never use and we had to know
they even had a trailer in the back that
we'd like have to bring all this crap
along with us
with so you know engineers are sort of
like the jack of all trades
and in wartime our life expectancy was
very very short because
we would probably be detached and each
squad would go with like an
infantry company or an armored company
and we would go out in front of them
and like clear obstacles which means
everybody would be shooting at us and
trying to kill us
while that's happening so
you know it was kind of an interesting
thing to do
so all right um
nominate says who's your favorite
philosopher to read who you mostly
disagree with
um that's yeah you know i i bet it is um
descartes i would say you know
i'm not a cartesian but i really love
reading
and teaching descartes and it's
interesting stuff you know
hume would be up there as well and so
would nietzsche you know
um all of them would fit in there
pretty pretty well uh a1 says go badgers
i am from wisconsin i don't i don't
actually care about the badgers
my mom and dad did my adopted mom and
dad because they
they were both uh my dad went to uh
university of wisconsin madison and you
know
um so they picked up a thing for that
but you know he died when i was 11 and
and i never got into the go badgers
thing
i'm i'm a packers fan and i i do like
our
uh um sort of second tier
ahl hockey team the admirals but that's
about it for me i don't pay much
attention to other sports
which is unfortunate because right now
the brewers in the box are pretty good
teams
but all right um
let's see here chris says my work
requires facilitating communication
between specialists from different
fields what's the most effective way to
improve your skills in conceptual
analysis through self-study
i don't know um but that that
that having to work with different
fields that's quite good i mean i would
say
you know studying human communications
which is there is
like a field out there but it's sort of
a hybrid thing that incorporates some
philosophy
and some linguistics and some psychology
and they they blend it all together and
sometimes it's a good combo sometimes
not i would say that's probably
helpful um
great uh tulias any religious thinkers
that interacted seriously with the work
of heidegger who you'd recommend that's
a good question but i don't think i have
a good answer
um i mean first of all i'm not like all
that conversant with the field of people
who
who did that and then ones to recommend
you know like i could talk about boltman
but i mean it's not gonna hurt you to
read boltman but i didn't find boltman
particularly illuminating
so i don't know um skip says how much is
anxiety tied to holding fast to
expectations that are unrealistic
well that's a good question um i would
say sometimes
it is if you and this is where the
stoics i think are particularly helpful
but existential analysis can be helpful
too
if you think that things have to be a
certain way
and if they aren't that way that that
you know everybody is going to hate you
or the world is going to fall apart or
stuff like that well that's going to
make you anxious as hell
because any given real thing almost
never turns out the way that we
imagine it's going to right so you know
great example of this is like
event planning right if you're an event
planner
and you're not able to roll with things
not
happening exactly the way that you've
planned them out
man that's going to suck for you you're
going to be anxious all the time
or angry or disappointed or whatever
the same thing can go for like classes
you know professors can
like i'm going to develop the syllabus
and it's all these wonderful things are
going to happen
and then the students come in and they
do things very differently
the way you want and the technology
doesn't work properly and now you can
become
quite anxious right so
all right uh a1 says if i seen the the
snyder cut no i don't i don't really get
into superhero
stuff that's what i understand the
snyder cut is about
um i i kind of steer clear of that
although i will say that i have been
my wife and i both have been very much
enjoying the show the boys which which
is quite good
um quite well done uh we'll see what
they do with season three because we
just finished season
two um but i i don't i don't spend much
time
you know i think part of what what
originally turned me off as superhero
movies
was how marvel managed to screw up the
x-men
early on um and
like went for easy sort of the thing
that like you're like yeah
this is the sort of thing like a
sophomore film student would like
totally geek out over but it's not a
good production
overall for somebody who actually cares
about it
and so i just i just don't get into it i
mean
life is short i got other stuff that i
do get into like you know
this we're gonna be talking about this
in two months
or david hume
or things like that so all right damon
says the day after tv show terrified me
as a kid so yeah that's a great
example i i think it was in the early
80s right
not the 70s and what we're talking about
there is a made-for-tv
movie that had two parts to it and it
was like
um you know we and the soviets went to
war and they dropped some
nuclear weapons in america which
produced fallout
radiation poisoning and you know all
sorts of
misery um you know we watched that and
we're like holy crap that could happen
you know we were pretty worried at the
time i think a lot of people
don't don't get that um how close we
were
horrible thoughts on dialectical
materialism that depends on who's you're
talking about i don't really have a lot
of thoughts on it as
as such um say it says
thanks for all the videos is there any
particular philosophical subject or
specific philosophical question that
particularly
interests me um you know i'm kind of all
over the map i have a lot of
different interests which makes it
difficult for me to get things
done or get them done on time um
you know the the question of like
causality determinism
freedom of the will i don't talk much
about free will but
freedom of the will and what the will is
that's something i'm very interested in
um you know where we're going as a human
species and culture i'm very interested
in that
obviously i'm interested in ancient
philosophy and medieval philosophy and
early modern stuff
how to apply philosophy to people's life
issues
that that's a big preoccupation of mine
as well
so um
all right wavy you're well versed in the
teachings of multiple philosophers or
multiple time periods
how do you keep track of each
philosopher's teachings and the
scholarly thought on their work
i don't you know i i don't read a lot of
secondary
literature unless i'm doing um
work on something um you know
usually academic stuff i don't i don't
need to you know i can read hegel i
don't need to read what
everybody else is saying about hegel um
life is short and i'd rather stick with
the the primary texts
um that said if i'm gonna write a piece
on hegel
then and it's on this particular stuff i
i read up on the secondary lit
but you know i don't necessarily like
exhaustively do that as if i was writing
a new dissertation
um so you know the answer is i don't
because you can't
um i do enjoy reading what intelligent
people have to say about
about thinkers who i like um
but that's often just not not in the
cards right
uh brandon says big question i'm
wondering how you think knowledge total
knowledge specifically or
encyclopediasism is different during the
first half of the 20th century
then in the 18th or 19th centuries was
hegel the last viable attempt to bring
all knowledge into unity
nobody's brought all knowledge into
unity nobody's um
ever in the history of things been
really encyclopedia
in that that sense they've been at best
semi-encyclopediac
um and everybody's gonna do it from some
sort of you know
guiding perspective so
the i mean the thing that's really
interesting is we we don't have to have
that in order to
be able to talk uh about
important things and make you know
well-guided decisions we don't have to
know the the totality of things
um and i think hagel did himself a
disservice
in trying to claim that sort of like
epistemological closure on his part that
that he didn't he didn't attain and
couldn't have as like required to be
able to say the things that he says
um so i i don't i just don't see
that as a viable project
um here's one from about heavy metal the
aldevar favorite heavy metal band now
versus when you were in your 20s
so when i was in my 20s i was listening
to
less and less metal actually um
as time went on and i was listening more
to stuff that was like
coming out but um was in like the grunge
to metal um
spectrum you know and i'll i'll qualify
that so
you know when i went to college in 1990
you know i brought a bunch of metal
tapes with me and i was playing bass and
i was you know playing a lot of iron
maiden and
black sabbath and judas priest and
and motorhead stuff um
on my base you know but i was also like
on metallica
you know first three albums i like had
the song sheets for that and i learned
every song they had
um but i started getting more into
the grunge stuff and listening to less
of that
and and also listening to bands that
were kind of on the edge of those both
like alice and chains you know
you know and i picked up other bands
like tool along the way
it'd be better to talk about like in my
teens when i was in my teens the
band for me as a metalhead was iron
maiden
they were like at the pinnacle right and
then every other band was
arranged below them so you could say
like you know well who's your second
favorite
um you know motorhead and wasp and judas
priest and raven
and rat you know dio and then we could
start going further down
and now if now i don't have a favorite
there are a lot of bands who from that
time period who i really like
and if i had to put together like my top
five
iron maiden would still be in there um
as with judas priest and motorhead
and dio would be in there as well and
then
you know who would be the fifth maybe
just if i consider like their entire
catalog black sabbath but that that's
not just aussie black sabbath that's dio
black sabbath that's gill and black
sabbath
that's martin black sabbath but there's
so many other
bands that i really like like tank or
girl school or
you know riot from from new york not to
be confused with quiet riot
or all these other bands that i've
gotten exposed to over time who turn out
to be really
awesome that i i didn't even know about
when i was when i was younger so
yeah there's there's a lot more uh so
here's a silly question from
feels okay have i heard of eastern
orthodoxy
you know i started out teaching
religious studies when
uh i had my first main teaching job and
obviously taught about eastern orthodoxy
then and that was almost 20 years ago
and i'd known about that
really since i was in my teens so yeah
all right uh oh so mark asks what are
some of your favorite songs to jam to
on your bass or banjo that's a great
question
um and um
so a lot of them are metal socks
strangely enough
um i i some of them i'm not as good at
as i'd like to be because i don't
practice like i should
but you know with judas priest i like to
play desert plains
and green manalishi with two prong crown
motorhead i like to play killed by death
no
class um
blanking on it's off of orgasmatron uh
it's the one about um
fighting uh you know sword and steel
uh uh you know there's a rictus grin
death forever you know i play that um
scorpion songs i like i like quite a few
of those i play some ufo songs i play
some some other stuff and then there's
you know there's some rock stuff
i actually kiss too i play some kiss
songs on my banjo
um but there's there's other bands too
whose stuff
i like i've actually got like my you
know i print out
um chords for myself
and then um you know
adapt it to the banjo so i've got my
whole
i need to fix this binder it's all it's
all messed up
but these are some examples
of the stuff oh yeah like gordon
lightfoot i like to play his stuff
quite a few of his songs play some
coldplay songs
um here's some allison chain stuff and
wasp
um neil young
you know i mean i could go on and on and
on oh here's an house cooper right 17
18 you know i like to play some duran
duran stuff as well
quite a bit um and
uh oh wow here's here's an actual like
here's a portuguese photo
song that i used to play maria sephora
um so you know it's pretty it's pretty
um eclectic
you know um
my wife's absolute favorite song and i
actually do play a lot of songs by this
band
cracker and she likes me to play i want
everything and every once in a while i
do that
uh as something you know sort of sort of
nice to do
it's pretty straightforward simple song
there's only four chords in it but
you know it's good so yeah a lot a lot
of different things i'd say
all right back to other questions um
dylan what philosopher do you think got
closest to proving god or had the most
interesting
things to say about and the metaphysics
that would have to be there for god to
be a reality
i don't think anyone got closest to
proving god he either
you know find some path you know we have
to think about what does proof mean
convinces every other human being in the
universe to
go along with it or provides you know a
path that a rational person
uh lacking you know impediments could
follow i mean
i'm a big fan of anselm um i think a lot
of people
don't read the actual text and they
they reconstruct the ontological
argument which anselm never calls
ontological by the way
uh and by the way the argument in
pro-slogan
is not just about god existing or having
being but about
being the supreme good and all the other
things we believe about god
i think handsome stuff is very
interesting um
you know i waver back and forth the way
other people have with the argument
um but it's it's got an interesting
architecture to it
so all right um
alternative it seems like many humans
enjoy believing and imagining things
that either don't exist
or that are extremely hard and
impossible for the existence to be
proven
how do you justify this tendency uh
could it be a human need or could be
based on some kind of intuition i would
say neither i would say that
i mean it could be based in human needs
plural
that come together in certain ways but
it also has to do with the fact that we
have language that can refer to itself
and you know we have the capacity to to
engage in imagination
and we are social beings and we exist in
histories and with tradition so we can
pick up other id
other people's ideas we're not all
reinventing it as we go along i think
all those
fit into it and
you know i think they're i think the
idea the focus on
their existence to be proven is usually
the wrong way to go
you know it's it's uh there's so much
focus on that
among philosophers and and people who
are philosophy adjacent
and there's not enough on like exploring
what the ideas actually
are and what they would what they would
mean you know um so a lot of times
people
this can't be proven oh okay
that often means you don't buy it or
you know somebody else uh isn't into it
but what's the i what's the actual idea
and then you ask them and their their
engagement with it is so thin it's nice
sometimes to kick around ideas even if
we don't
we don't buy into them entirely you know
all right um
per person paren says socrates moxed
anxious who stated the sun and moon were
only material substances not gods was he
the equivalent to a flat earther
or was all this an attempt to not appear
atheist i wouldn't say either
you know um i would say it was mocking
you know
i wouldn't read too much into that uh
ertius what do you recommend to read if
i enjoy nietzsche's philosophy so
i'm assuming that means you've already
read nature
i don't know read the people there's so
many people who are influenced by
nietzsche
right um that you could follow them out
mock schaler has a wonderful little book
on rizontomont
um you know rainer maria rilke got
introduced to
nietzsche by his lover lou andreas
salome who
had traveled with nietzsche and who
wrote a book on nietzsche
um you know there's there's lots and
lots of people that you could you could
look at who were influenced and then you
can see
you know you can probably read a little
bit and be like ah this isn't for me
you know but some of them you might you
might find to be
interesting interlocutors with nature
interpreters of nietzsche
all right um
james some argue that kantian deontology
is too demanding but couldn't we say
similar
about virtue ethics it seems tough to
develop moral character in this world
or am i missing something yeah you're
missing the fact that just because
something is difficult
doesn't mean you should give it up um i
mean if you want to be a
conscientiontologist live as a
deontologist see if you can do it if you
want to be a virtue ethicist live as a
virtue ethicist
see if you can make progress in virtue
it's it's it's sort of like
starting at the very beginning of
something and being like nah
i i can only see five yards into this
building
but i think it's not for me even though
the building goes on for a mile
you know um i i i think a lot of these
oh it's too difficult to to do
things are basically people wanting to
make it easy for themselves
um i mean you can say the same thing
about stoic ethics and and the response
to that epictetus says is
be the purple thread you know in the
the white garment um so what if
everybody can't do it doesn't mean you
can't do it
right um the inverted form i'm almost
done reading the phenomenology with a
reading group i'm very proud this is
one i've been intimidated by for a long
time what's a good follow-up
reading the phenomenology again and and
seeing how much more
you you get out of it the next time i
mean if you follow
hegel's own thing you're supposed to
read the science of logic next
that's a real head cracker i don't know
how much you'll actually get out of it
you could you know like read the
philosophy of write or any of his
lectures
you know uh he's got lots of great
lecture stuff
lectures on the philosophy of history
lectures on the history of philosophy
lectures on aesthetics lectures on the
philosophy of religion we could go on
and on it's
it's really up to you but if you the
next time you do read the phenomenology
you will find that
you're seeing stuff that you missed the
last time around
you know all right uh
john asked me about a text i haven't
read um
young's wotan essay i haven't read it um
i haven't read peter sloater dick have i
read dineen's why liberalism
failed no i haven't read any of those
those those things
um wavy
what's the process of translating
non-english language works of philosophy
into english
are some languages harder to translate
than others the process is you translate
it
you know there there's no there's no
like process to it you just
translate and then check it your
translation and have somebody else check
your translation and
fix your what went wrong in it it's it's
i don't know
what you mean by a process
all right uh singularity want to say
congratulations on reaching
a hundred thousand i just skipped a
little bit
[Music]
um
boy a lot of a lot of questions here
more than i'm going to actually get to
unfortunately here we go it's a
tremendous accomplishment considering
the content rigor depth of your videos
inspiration for those seeking to do the
same
thanks that's that's really great um
so yeah i i it's it's been a while
we're gonna have a party tomorrow
another one of these events i'm gonna
talk a little bit about that process
then
um so let me let me jump on to the next
one
uh dd don't jews consider the talmud uh
the old testament
well that's not the same thing so the
talmud is commentary
to be you mean torah right to be
metaphors oral history life lessons in
other words they don't take it
literally like christians tend to do
depends on which jewish people you're
talking to there's a
wide variety some do take it completely
literally others don't you know
so i wouldn't i wouldn't try to
generalize um
all right i'm going to
skip down a bit um
to things that are a bit easier to
uh get
damn it albert dr sadler you seem to
despise intro level of history of
philosophy overview sorts of things but
you know of any ones you might recommend
i don't despise them i put them in their
proper context they're not the original
text
and many of them are actually wrong so
if you think that's despising i think
that's more about
what you're reading into it than what i
actually think
um primary texts are primary text
secondary text or secondary text some
secondary texts are
so good they become primary texts like
you know when
heidegger is is you know talking about
what's going on in nietzsche that's
basically like a
in between primary and secondary text a
lot of other people's stuff on nietzsche
is not worth your time
um so yeah any any ones i might
recommend yeah i always say
you know if you want to if you really
want a history of philosophy friedrich
cobleston
he's got a history of philosophy he's
not going to steer you wrong
he's definitely not going to give you
everything that's there in the text but
you know it's it's decent stuff
all right um
carlos says i want to read edmond hustle
what do you recommend me
when i teach historial i have my
students read the cartesian meditations
and hustle's own article encyclopedia
article on phenomenology because you get
him explaining what
what he takes phenomenology to be doing
right
so all right novan what do you think
about heidegger's criticism of starts
existentialism what's the critical
difference between existentialism and
metaphysics there isn't a critical
difference between
existentialism and metaphysics
metaphysics you know often gets done in
an existentialist way
heidegger's criticism of sart's
existentialism was that sartre
is misinterpreting some of the things
that heidegger is saying and he's much
too humanistic about it i would say
these are two different kinds of
existentialism
you know um plato's rave says time to
get you a copy of fang numina then well
if you do that i'll be
be very grateful and i'll i'll do a
review of it
um all right let's see
i'm gonna skip down a little bit um
questions that are that we're gonna get
more mileage out of right
um well here's a
so hey doc thoughts on curtis yarvin
uh mencius moldbug and and the uh
um whole idea that he's been out there
for quite a while i've i've actually
read him quite a bit in the past
and i i see a lot of these you know
whatever you want to call them uh neo
reactionaries
traditionalists of sorts is not they're
engaging with new content
but they're often just doing the same
stuff as traditionalists or
neo-reactionaries did
and you know after the french revolution
or with accion francaise in the 20th
century
i don't see a lot of originality of
analysis there
it's often interesting to read because
you can get a pulse on
where people are going with this stuff
but yeah i'm
sort of like reading charles marah um
all right uh twl i'm doing research
that's based on philosophy
of solitude any suggestions concerning
existentialist philosophers who have
connections to this philosophy
i don't know about a philosophy of
solitude that sounds like something that
somebody made up to try to like corner a
little bit of the market themselves the
way people often do
there's philosophy that engages with
solitude and so there's like a long
tradition in
german philosophy of talking about ein
zamkite
so rilka thematizes that in letters to a
young poet and
actually in several different poems uh
nietzsche talks about
you know the the solitary person for
example in
the spokes arthur there's an entire
chapter right
um so you know the existentialists
they won't always use that term solitude
so you got to do a bit of
connecting the dots gabriel marcel talks
about those sorts of things sart talks
about those sorts of things de bevoir
talks about those sort of things
um i think you can like read through
well love chest off too
you can read through the existentialist
spectrum and and get a lot out of that
um stoics talk about it epictetus
actually has a whole chapter
devoted to it there's a lot of
discussions of of um
solitaryness in the monastic literature
um in in you know late antiquity going
into the middle ages
so that might be quite useful as well
all right
um let's see here
let's see uh
well seeking truth why are so many
leftist wisdom seekers when locusm and
wisdom are incompatible
how would you know that that's that's a
pretty sweeping philosophical statement
i mean first off you have to be able to
define what what wokism means and then
that better conform to what other people
mean by it but
those aren't incompatible any more than
like being anti-woke is incompatible
with wisdom now is it
or being somebody to use a jargon like
that is incompatible with wisdom
carl alberting how would you define
philosophy i wouldn't define philosophy
it's it's a mistake to try to define
philosophy
at best you can arrive at a definition
later on after doing stuff
um wolf says how could you
could you tell us about your personal
experience in the academic world as a
professor of philosophy nowadays
how it's changed over time um oh yeah
it's it's it's gone from something
you know so the good old days were
before i was
became a professor and that was the
people who taught us
they remembered that when there was
plenty of money
flowing around and jobs were easy to
find and
being a professor often didn't mean a
lot of oversight
or you know it was kind of a nice life
for many people
and that's when you know most of the
teaching was actually done by professors
and not
not adjuncts throughout my entire career
you know that has not been the case my
first teaching job was
a year-to-year contract where i couldn't
get tenure or promotion just because of
the way things were set up
teaching in a maximum security prison
full-time and then i went down to a
struggling hbcu
where i actually was up for early tenure
in promotion
and then left uh so i could be together
with my now wife
up in new york then i since then i've
adjuncted
and i got to see you know how i mean
i've been kind of fortunate in
in the way that adjuncting has worked
out for me
especially in the last few years where i
get more requests to teach than i can
actually fill
because i've got like 20 years
experience and you know people know me
but um it's brutal you know the
publisher parish thing
that's been ramped up the telling
people they need to have publications
before they graduate to even be
like considered for jobs um the
precarity
of academic positions even if you get
tenure
one of the places that i teach phased
out 15 departments
in their their college and that meant
they were allowed to fire those
professors
and then some of them were hired back as
adjuncts it's it's a tough
tough gig you know and the people who
are doing well at it are usually the
ones in the elite institutions who have
you know great pedigrees and
are part of a self-replicating elite and
they have no idea what it's like for
everybody else you know
um and and you know they they're usually
the ones who have the bully pulpits
so you know like for for example you
know the whole cornell west not getting
tenure
at harvard thing that is so far removed
from
the experience of most academics that
frankly
they probably you know it's sort of like
watching
tv shows about people struggling in some
sci-fi universe compared to their own
real experience
so you know it it's gotten very tough
um from for many people in the academic
fields
so all right mark
asks have i ever taken the ferry from
manitowoc to ludington across lake
michigan i've never taken the ferry
period which i think you can catch in
milwaukee
there's no reason i would drive up to i
i mean
manitowoc wouldn't it be green bay i
don't know how far
up it goes but all right i'm gonna we've
got about
nine minutes left so i'm gonna pick some
questions that are easy
to grapple with i apologize to those i
can't get to
um let's see what we got here
so here's a good question what do you
think about promoting philosophers like
plato aristotle heidegger who are on
record saying sexist racist generally
exclusionary
statements surely you should condemn
them you can condemn the statements that
doesn't mean you have to condemn the
philosophers and oftentimes you use the
resources of those philosophers to say
aristotle said this boneheaded thing he
should have said this and there's
resources in that
this sweeping we must condemn i think
that's a
sort of foolish way to go about things
and it doesn't what do we have left over
then
you know all right
let's see here
[Music]
zebra standards do you think
phenomenology is something which has
stopped developing and is just a
historical study
or do you see interesting developments
in phenomenology by contemporary
thinking there's a lot of
people doing phenomenology there's a
vast movement out there that you can
easily
google and there are people still doing
quite interesting
work in phenomenology um you know
oftentimes it's informed by
previous thinkers right and it'll be
done like you know if you go to the
north american
shaler society some of the stuff will be
like this is you know what shaler's
talking about here and then it'll be
like here's how shaler applies to
disability or
you know uh here's what shaler would
have to say a schaelerian perspective on
current political debate you know and so
there's there's a lot of
quite vital stuff going on i would say
there's bruce
uh hey bruce good to see you here
um oh here's a great question
um what's my thoughts on the potential
ecological crisis we're heading for
yeah it's it's it's potential only in
the sense that like we do have the
potential to like maybe veer away from
it and mitigate some of the effects
we're screwed if we don't get our act
together um
you know and uh we we do have the
capacity that we've attained within the
last
roughly 100 or so years to really
really damage and screw up this this
planet
and we we kind of have to get our [ __ ]
together
um and figure out what we're going to do
to keep things from from uh really going
off
off kilter so i don't know that we have
the political chops
these days to do that unfortunately
um
all right let's see what else we got
here
moxat what are the differences between
stoics and spinoza in regards to
conception of god well the stoics don't
conceive of god as just one single
substance that has two attributes that
we can
understand but infinite attributes it's
different cosmologies
so you know that's a big part
um
gustaf what's your take on capital
punishment
i'm not against capital punishment per
se i think that the way that we
administer it here in america and i can
only only talk about here
is pretty racist and classist
and really poorly guided and very often
we execute people
20 years after they've been convicted
and have gone through all these appeals
and are quite often different people
there are you know interestingly when i
when i taught at indiana state prison
that was the prison where executions
were carried out in indiana
at the time some people might can get
confused because they saw about like you
know the recent
rash of executions under the trump
administration in terre haute indiana
that's the federal
system indiana system it was michigan
city
indiana state prison and when
whenever they were doing an execution
they would lock the place down because
the prisoners fight quite often felt
solidarity with
some of the people being executed
there were some prisoners who even the
prisoners were like that guy deserves to
die
you know he he should have died years
ago and so you know i think
things like that are worth taking into
account um
it may be that it's it's practically
impossible in an institutional way to
have a just use of capital punishment
in the united states at present and i
think the people who are
like really pro-capital punishment very
often when you look at them they're
really pro
retribution and and that's that's what
they're into
all right uh edwin boyette rating do you
under rat sounds like a hemlock worthy
offense
i didn't do that i don't know what you
were listening to but
dio and rad are both really you know top
tier bands
um let's see here
detour what in your opinion would be the
best book to introduce someone to
stoicism epictetus is in caribbean
and then marcus aurelius's meditations
and then maybe seneca's
unhappy life you know nice short works
that can be
read that are gateways i mean if you
want to read secondary sources you go
right on ahead but
why not jump right into the the straight
stuff you know
um rather than get somebody else's
pre-digested
um things you know um
let's see here poetic or any chance of
getting some
jean baudrillard videos um you know i'm
usually shooting stuff on
who i'm teaching i'm not i don't teach
baldriard very often
but if somebody wants to commission them
they can always reach out to me i've
done commissioned videos in the past
rush paul you've lectured about so many
different philosophers do you imagine
you'll talk about schopenhauer anytime
soon yeah i've actually got some that
i've been meaning to shoot some core
concept videos
um on on his discussions of ethics
um just never got to it probably will
this summer
you know hoping to um
let's see here eric
do you listen to other genres of metal
besides hair
hair is not a genre um classic metal
you know is so
donna weinstein who you should probably
read she's got a great sociology of
metal
she talks about in the 80s there being
three big like
super genres the sort of middle of the
road what we call
traditional classic heavy metal which
includes iron maiden
judas priest motorhead dio that's not
hair metal
that's that's something quite different
when we talk about hair metal we're
talking usually about glam
you know softer sound
you know a bit more production and then
there's like thrash
and and you know early black sort of
extreme metal over there
and so hair metal if you if you're using
hair metal to describe
um classic metal you're misusing
the term and it's better to talk about
glam or pop or stuff like that for
you know winger or cinderella or poison
or stuff like that
i've never really been that into that
the one band that
is definitely in that segment in terms
of looks
actually two bands that i i like but
they've got a harder edge to them
but i've always liked our twisted sister
and and rant motley crew actually i only
like their only the very early stuff i
didn't like
theater pain i thought they'd kind of
gone off the
deep end there are some bands that look
glam but have a harder edge to them as
well like lizzie borden who
who i like but you really want to like
if you're gonna if you're gonna
generalize about metal you've got to get
these
these these uh terms down in some ways
all right uh let's go out on one more
if we can
um
[Music]
let's see here
there's something in here oh yeah
adventurous rover have you studied
transcendentalism what are your thoughts
so transcendentalism is like a kind of a
movement it's not a
single philosophy and yeah i've i've
studied it and i've taught it in classes
i'm not an expert on it but i i find it
enjoyable you know
one interesting thing by the way they
got their understanding
of what was happening in germany largely
through
uh samuel coleridge who did did a good
bit of writing on that
that stuff um
let's see any other
easy things to tackle uh well here's
here's a good one to to go out on and i
my advice to you is going to be
unfortunately there's not much you can
do
zack says i have a friend who can't stop
talking about jordan peterson
any advice on how to get him to read
around more all he does is watch
peterson without checking his sources or
reading the people he accuses of pomo
not much you can do with somebody like
that i mean i i would actually like set
down limits and say
you know and i've done this with people
in the past who are like totally fixated
on some
second rate you know not very deep
often quite confused um
you know semi-philosophical stuff you
say listen
i've heard what you say about that i'm
not interested in that if you want to
have a conversation about something else
hit me up and i'll be happy to do that
but i've heard your shtick
and i'm not i'm not into that um
and if that means that we can't hang out
much anymore that sucks for you
sucks for me but that's your choice
buddy um
you know and and you could you also keep
the door open and say like you know when
you're done with that
come see me and sometimes people do that
and sometimes people don't sometimes
they're like screw you
who are you to tell me blah blah blah
blah that's a sign that you're probably
not going to maintain that friendship
that it's
too much is being demanded on your end
and they're not giving what they ought
to be giving
and then you know like seneca says when
you lose a friend
find another friend you know you can
find people who
aren't so uh into that and this is a
natural process that has to happen
so all right well i didn't get to
everybody's questions
i never do but thanks everybody for
joining me
i will be having the 100 000
subscriber party tomorrow uh all of you
are welcome to join for that we're gonna
celebrate hitting that milestone
after only 10 years i'm going to talk a
little bit about
getting there and about some of the
plans i've got for
the channel going forward but thanks
everybody for joining me in the good
questions
and comments and i will either see you
there or see a next ama or
one of the other online events